the political and legal fight over
election laws and the right to vote is
getting more intense this morning
democrats in congress are pushing one
proposal that would affect all americans
while republicans are going state by
state attacking efforts to make voting
easier
ed o'keefe is with us now ed good
morning to you so the supreme court
just heard arguments on some voting
restrictions in arizona
that's right tony lower courts had said
that these two laws disproportionately
affect
voters of color one of them has to do
with
provisional ballots that are cast in the
wrong precinct often
accidentally the other has to do with
the collection of your absentee ballot
somebody might pick it up and drop it
off at the polling site
critics call that ballot harvesting the
high court likely going to keep these
two laws in place
but the hearing about them revealed one
of the reasons why democrats and
republicans keep fighting over these
kinds of laws
under questioning from supreme court
justice amy coney barrett the attorney
for arizona republicans explained
part of the reason why they want to keep
the laws on the books is pure politics
it puts us at a competitive disadvantage
relative to democrats politics is a
zero-sum game
and every extra vote they get through
unlawful interpretations of section two
hurts us that zero-sum game appears to
be part of what's driving the voting
rights debate
in washington democrats controlling the
house are pushing through a plan that
they say would expand voting rights and
establish
new national standards for automatic
voter registration
and how elections are conducted we can
deliver the gold
standard of reforms to protect the right
of americans to vote
republicans say it goes too far under
the constitution we
generally defer to states and counties
to run elections
democrats want to change that but in
more than 40 states
republicans are the ones trying to
change election laws
with more than 250 proposals that
critics say would curb at least some
voter access in georgia there are
proposals to limit access to absentee
ballots
add id requirements and restrict the
number of weekend early voting days
republicans say the changes address
unsubstantiated concerns
about alleged widespread election fraud
that an integrity of an election is just
as important as access
to an election democrats say they would
disenfranchise minority voters
you are choosing to support a bill that
is so egregious
that it is nationally known as jim crow
in a suit and tie so that's in atlanta
down in georgia here in washington
democrats today
that bill they're going to pass in the
house it's called the for the people act
it's going to sail through with just
democratic support but it's likely dead
in the senate where it would require
republican support to clear a filibuster
we'll see what happens
meanwhile over at the white house
president biden has pulled the
nomination for his budget chief near a
tandem
withdrew her nomination last night amid
bipartisan criticism of for lack of a
better term
mean tweets about members of both
parties
the white house says they're going to
find something else for her to do
instead that doesn't require
senate confirmation tony now the
definition of mean tweets is pretty
elastic given the tweets of the the
former president uh i'm curious
joe biden cannot be accused of rushing
to remove this uh nomination he stuck
with it for quite a long time how come
well a few reasons one they wanted to
keep tannen in place because
uh you know she represents some history
she would have been the first indian
american to hold that job she's one of
the women
that they're trying to get nominated to
senior posts the other is that they were
under the belief that they could get at
least one republican vote for this
given that at least one democrat had
said they weren't uh
interested in confirming her but
ultimately the horse trading that was
going on
they determined that it just couldn't
happen suppose the moral of the story is
tony
just watch your tweets that was exactly
what i was going to say ed
well well put all right thank you very
much